i don't know if anyone else has noticed this
but if you look up sodium lauryl sulfate in
a clean beauty app it's usually rated as clean
but sodium laureth sulfate is usually rated
as dirty
these apps are terrible and based on pseudoscience
sls and sles are both safe in your products
but if you're a skincare nerd you'll know
that sls is considered harsher on your skin
than sles so what's with these ratings?
there's actually a really interesting story
behind this about an innovation that's so
useful it's everywhere in skincare hair care
beauty but i think most people have never
heard of it i'm michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and cosmetic chemist
and today i'm going to be talking about the
science of ethoxylation how it turned into
this fear-mongering and why you'll probably
hear a lot more of this fear-mongering over
the next couple of years
this video is sponsored by croda a cosmetics
ingredient supplier who make tons of ingredients
that you find in your products both ethoxylated
and non-ethoxylated but as always all the
ingredients in this video are my own croda
did not supply them
if you look on the backs of your products
you'll see this in a lot of ingredient names
"eth" a lot of the time not always these three
little letters means that the ingredient is
ethoxylated there's sodium laureth sulfate
of course but there's also anything that ends
in eth and a number laureth beheneth cetereth
glycereth
isethionate ingredients
there are also other ethoxylated ingredients
too without the eth for example anything with
peg and polysorbates all of these ingredients
are ethoxylated
ethoxylation means you take an ingredient
and you add little units containing two carbon
atoms that's what the eth means in chemistry
and an oxygen which is the oxy part for example
this is the structure of sodium lauryl sulfate
and here is sodium laureth sulfate you can
see the extra added ethoxylation part this
particular sodium laureth sulfate molecule
has two extra added ethoxyl units these little
units are really important in changing the
properties of an ingredient
most of these ethoxylated ingredients are
surfactants surfactants have one end that
lacks oil and one end that likes water they're
really important because if you think about
it a lot of skin care and beauty is about
trying to get oil and water to mix which is
the thing that surfactants are best at for
example when you're cleansing your face or
washing your hair you're trying to get oil
to rinse off into water when you put on a
moisturizer you're trying to add oil and water
to your skin in the one product so oil and
water have to hang out and behave together
nicely a lot of fragrances are oily but a
lot of the time you have water-based products
that you might want to make fragranced surfactants
are key to making all of these work
the main reason ethoxylation is so useful
is that it adds oxygen to the structure oxygen
is an element with special properties and
the main one is that it can form special bonds
with water called hydrogen bonds so ethoxylation
will make an ingredient like water more the
more of these ethoxy units that you add in
the more water loving it'll be so ethoxylation
is really useful for fine tuning how much
an ingredient prefers water versus oil and
therefore the specific properties of the overall
product
the other big impact is that ethoxylation
increases the size of the surfactant and this
means that it doesn't penetrate skin as easily
this makes this effect much more gentle on
skin and this is why sles is so much gentler
than sls even though they're both sulfates
one study found that sles could be gentler
than sls as well as a whole bunch of other
non-sulfate surfactants so thanks to ethoxylation
we can have cleansing surfactants that are
gentle on skin but still foam really well
micellar waters with surfactants that can
clean skin effectively but they're so gentle
that you don't need to rinse them off cleansing
balms that apply like an oil but rinse off
cleanly superfatting agents in cleansers shampoos
and conditioners that act like water-soluble
oils so your skin and hair can be moisturized
and conditioned while still rinsing clean
but here's the catch ethoxylation is linked
with the chemical 1,4-dioxane 1,4-dioxane
isn't intentionally added to your products
it doesn't have a purpose in beauty but it's
formed as a by-product during ethoxylation
and it ends up as a trace contaminant it hitches
a ride along with ethoxylated ingredients
that are purposely added to the product
during the ethoxylation process you're adding
these little ethoxy units with two carbons
and one oxygen to your ingredient but sometimes
instead of reacting with the ingredient two
ethoxy units will join together and you end
up with this ring and this is 1,4-dioxane
our by-product
1,4-dioxane is not nice the main concern is
that it's suspected to be a human carcinogen
even though it hasn't been properly linked
to cancer in humans the evidence that it causes
cancer in animals is strong enough to believe
that it could happen in humans too so it's
probably a good idea not to be exposed to
too much of it there are two ways we can potentially
be exposed to 1,4-dioxane through our beauty
products firstly when we use products with
traces of 1,4-dioxane most of the 1,4-dioxane
evaporates into the air but some of it can
be absorbed through skin and some of it could
be inhaled cleansing products like body wash
and shampoo have the highest amounts of 1,4-dioxane
not surprising because they also have the
highest amount of surfactants surfactants
are their active cleansing ingredients
there are also some differences between how
different ingredients are made that changes
how much 1,4-dioxane ends up in them sles
usually has the highest amounts of contamination
because of how it's made but the levels of
1,4-dioxane in beauty products have actually
dropped a lot over the years ingredient manufacturers
have been working on reducing the amounts
of 1,4-dioxane without there being any laws
in place there are ways to produce the ethoxylated
ingredients with less 1,4-dioxane and there
are ways to remove a lot of the excess 1,4-dioxane
afterwards and these have been really effective
the fda has monitored how much 1,4-dioxane
is in beauty products from the us over the
years in 1981 the average amount was 50 parts
per million which is equivalent to one drop
in a giant one liter bottle of shampoo by
1997 the average amount had more than dropped
by half to 19 parts per million so a bit less
than half a drop in here in 2008 the fda conducted
another survey of 35 products the highest
level detected was 11.6 parts per million
eighty percent of the products had levels
below one part per million which is less than
one fiftieth of a drop in this bottle the
amount considered safe in beauty products
is slightly different around the world 10
parts per million is the limit recommended
by the scientific committee for consumer safety
in the eu this is the amount that they calculated
would cause one extra person in 7.5 million
to get cancer per year or the equivalent increased
lifetime risk of cancer if you smoked half
a cigarette per year for 60 years but like
you saw the vast majority of products don't
have this much anyway so you don't have to
be all ewg about it
new york recently changed their laws to limit
1,4-dioxane in cosmetics to 10 parts per million
by the end of 2022 but they've gone further
with household cleaning and personal care
products the ones that you rinse off your
skin 1,4-dioxane in these will be limited
to two parts per million by the end of 2022
and one part per million by the end of 2023
so why do the things that don't stay on our
skin have tighter limits?
well it's because of the other and overall
bigger concern 1,4-dioxane is a drinking water
contaminant and this is a very real problem
1,4-dioxane absorbs easily from your digestive
system a lot of places do have quite high
levels of dioxane in their drinking water
and most places don't have laws on the allowed
level of 1,4-dioxane so the idea is cosmetics
stay on your body but personal care products
which is defined as cleansing products including
shampoo conditioner soap and bath products
these go down the drain into the waterways
which eventually becomes drinking water
so i guess limiting 1,4-dioxane in personal
care products does make sense in theory but
i'm skeptical it's going to do much 1,4-dioxane
is a trace contaminant in personal care products
but it's used intentionally in much larger
quantities in other industries it's a solvent
that's used in paints inks cleaning making
plastics
1,4-dioxane was most commonly used as an additive
to stabilize chlorinated solvents which were
phased out as part of the montreal protocol
also known as the one time the world actually
got together and did something about an environmental
disaster the montreal protocol banned the
use of substances that destroyed the ozone
layer and the main chlorinated solvent that
1,4-dioxane was used with was banned in 1996
so the use of 1,4-dioxane has actually dropped
massively from its peak in the 80s in the
us it's dropped to about 1/25th of the amount
used at the peak but every year about 1 million
pounds which is half a million kilograms if
you're in a country that uses real numbers
that much dioxane is used every year and in
2016 62 000 pounds which is 28 000 kilograms
of that was released into the water
so we can do a calculation to work out how
much shower gel and shampoo you'd have to
use to release that amount of dioxane into
the water if your products have an average
of two parts per million every single person
in the US would have to rinse 43.5 liters
of beauty products down the drain every year
that is about one-third of this mug or 24
palm-sized dollops of product every day and
even then these amounts that are currently
released by industry every year aren't thought
to be the biggest contributor to 1,4-dioxane
in drinking water the amounts of 1,4-dioxane
used decades ago before chlorinated solvents
were phased out were much much higher there
are lots of old industrial areas and improperly
lined disposal sites that are contaminated
with 1,4-dioxane and this can leach into underground
water which is where a lot of our drinking
water comes from
a 2017 study found that dioxane in contaminated
water was correlated with chlorinated solvent
levels and this points towards the old industrial
uses as the main culprit in new york where
this law is being introduced supposedly to
improve drinking water it's long island that
has particularly contaminated water and it's
thought that it's because there are lots of
old industrial sites there and their drinking
water comes from underground aquifers so to
me it seems like a much better approach would
be to treat the industrial sites either way
these new limits are coming in at the end
of the year in new york
so i think this whole thing is a really interesting
story that highlights a lot of themes that
come up a lot in the beauty discourse
firstly really amazing innovations can become
a victim of their own success things that
get really popular also get really scrutinized
and if there's any sort of fearmongering that
can be done you know that certain sections
of the beauty industry are going to try their
best to take advantage of it
crystal ball time i think we're probably going
to see some 1,4-dioxane scare stories around
the end of the year when these restrictions
start taking place which will be a great christmas
present for me
i also think that other places will make similar
changes because theme number two sometimes
the easy things get regulated and the hard
but more important things get ignored sometimes
maybe lawmakers genuinely don't understand
the issue but sometimes this can be a strategic
decision to look like they're doing something
it acts as a smoke screen for inaction setting
a limit that manufacturers have to meet is
cheap and easy but remediating industrial
sites is a lot harder new york is going to
evaluate whether this law actually worked
in 2025 and i do think they'll say it did
because dioxane's actually been going down
anyway plus scientists are developing lots
of ways of getting dioxane out of wastewater
and drinking water i hope someone will do
an analysis to see if the personal care product
limit will make a difference because i could
be wrong
plus the beauty industry does proactively
do good things without being forced to by
specific regulations the catch is that a lot
of it does depend on what they feel like consumers
want so we need to be asking for the right
things not things that are based on misunderstandings
of what the real issues are
one of the really exciting things happening
in the industry is that a lot of ingredient
suppliers are coming out with sustainability
innovations and these will probably filter
down to us over time for example croda's eco
ethoxylated surfactant range this is 100%
bio-based and renewable and made with renewable
energy so there's less reliance on fossil
fuels a lot of the time going more natural
can mean that it's more resource intensive
but these eco ingredients still have a lower
carbon footprint than the petrochemical versions
these still perform as well as those versions
and of course they all have low 1,4-dioxane
i'm going to stick these predictions behind
the curtain behind me someone remind me to
check at the end of the year links to more
videos should be coming up if you want to
keep watching